welcome back to las vegas now our very
own cooking confidence coach manny bubby
is back in studio thanks to chapman
automotive the sponsors of this next
segment today we are learning how to
make roasted vegetables there you go
simple but it's complex it's really a
knife skills class are you ready yes
so many students that say oh my gosh i
just i hate to work with knives i can't
do what everybody else does you know
those chefs
exactly so and i just told you the the
most i work with is a steak knife and a
butter knife and that's a problem
because it really is because if you come
home and you say oh i want to cook for
myself tonight and you see a recipe that
says chop dice or mince you're like nope
i'm going through the drive-through i'm
done so we want to get you over that
understand me okay i understand you so
which do you think would be more
comfortable to you the larger one or the
smaller larger okay take the i'm sorry
about that all right so here's the thing
about holding it okay how do you hold it
what makes you feel comfortable this
okay so i would just say just choke up a
tiny bit just a tiny bit okay how does
that feel good okay so the thing about a
knife is what you want to do is you want
to make sure that you're comfortable
okay that's the only thing everybody
says hold it up here and hold it down
don't just hold it to how you're
comfortable how am i doing is we're
going to look natural yes you look
natural okay ready
we're going to start with bell peppers
see these veins right here yes this is a
game changer ready
down okay
down okay already failing you got it no
no you got it that's it okay down
down oh and down okay
down okay there you go okay you got it
okay so i can see that's wrong we want
to know what's right let me just show
you this really quick okay you want to
cut back here okay so oh i was cutting
from the top of the knife no it's the
back that's where the leverage is and
the strength got because i'm learning in
real time right now okay yeah she is
really actually learning in real time
okay so then just really quickly i'm
going to show you you're going to take
these again towards the back
you're going to just okay now we're
slicing
yeah towards the back towards the back
yeah go down oh wait no yeah you got it
okay one more time
hold on okay okay so like from the back
to the front there you go okay there you
go okay all right just throw that onto
your sheet pan
okay so the next thing we're going to do
is a zucchini okay so the best thing to
do is end out again off into the compost
basket over here
now you look at that there you go now
you want to have that there you go now
you want to have this you don't want to
slice this because it's going to go
rolling everywhere right so you're going
to just go down the middle starting from
the tip
move your hand oh my god hold it on top
over the top okay there you go and down
rule number one yeah move your hand move
your hand okay down
there you go that's great rocky okay
good yeah now just hold it flat turn it
flat
that's my girl oh my god okay and now
down okay
and down
okay
oh shoot the other vet yeah thank you
there you go okay down that's it okay
now just hold it hold this at the end
and just chop down oh the fun part okay
all right and just throw that into the
sheet we've got a minute 30 now okay
with your yellow with your yellow squash
you would do the same thing but you're
not going to do it because we've run out
of time right okay so i'm just going to
show you this
with an onion you slice it down
this is for dicing you slice down but
see how they're already cut so you're
going to just cut like that and then
when you cut the opposite way they're
automatically diced boom okay i have one
thing for you okay okay grab your
unpeeled garlic
got it okay by the way it smells
delicious yeah so there's your own
peeled garlic okay we're gonna take this
oh yeah i know this tree i think i know
this do you know this trick no but no
so you're gonna take the flat fat part
of the knife one minute right down boom
okay one two three
that's it get it okay and now it's
overpowered so when it comes to mincing
garlic what you want to do is you want
to use all the garlic the more garlic
you have the easier it is to mince okay
that's the one thing when it comes to
mincing something like rosemary leaves
you um you want to do small amounts as
possible listen i want to tell you this
one trick i saw in tick tock it's really
quick to wash your leafy vegetables
rinse them three times don't put them in
the salad spinner just go out back
and what i love that
oh that's a baby and that's a good part
for the kids so we've got love machine
pan ready here's
[Music]
i'll hold this to try this
oh my gosh this is such a blessing thank
you hot
hot hot delicious flavorful
main seasoning on that or salt and
pepper and olive oil that's it there you
go hey you're learning to ask there you
go all right all right everybody so
check out danny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com also we want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring the
countdown on the count of three go out
and spread love we'll be right back
[Music]